this podcast has bad words
how do you maintain minimalism in your
kitchen specifically the kitchen
cupboards
fridge freezer i'm going to start in
none of those places
i want to start with flat surfaces
so it's important to me that we have as
few things as possible
on our flat surfaces well why is this
because flat surfaces are the easiest
place for us to just simply store things
yeah it's really easy i'll just throw my
junk mail right there on the counter and
then it piles up
yeah and having all of these
accoutrements all over the counter it
piles
up so i have a coffee maker there i have
a coffee grinder i have the things that
i use every day we also bought an air
fryer last year during the pandemic
because we started cooking
even more at home than usual and i
wanted alternate ways to make
some different things and so it's mainly
our sweet potato maker
but it it it will serve a purpose in
other ways these are things i use daily
or almost daily certainly weekly
and and even then if there was a place
in my cabinets for the air fryer i would
put it down there as well i just have
a very very small kitchen those of you
who have seen
my home tour or actually if you just
sell less is now you saw
me and ella and bex in the kitchen which
is for some reason
it's the smallest area of our entire
house yeah yeah and that's why this
question is so appealing to me
because because it's the smallest area
in our house it's almost
we don't live in a tiny house but we
have a tiny kitchen
uh and so it feels like we live in a
tiny house whenever we
because as soon as i go in the kitchen
murphy's law dictates that bex and ella
follow me into the kitchen
and stand wherever i need to be they
just love being around you
i'll tell you my cousin has a tiny house
his kitchen is bigger than yours
how great is that so yeah uh i will tell
you this um
i own quite a few things that are dual
purpose
tri-purpose quad purpose quint purpose
correct me on that podcast sean uh
sext purpose not sex purpose sean calm
down
he's getting out of control over there
look at his eyes
sex toys are in the closet uh not in the
kitchen in the kitchen thank god i do
have a bottle of lube in the kitchen but
that's a different story just imagining
what sex toys would double as a kitchen
utensil and a sex toy
yeah this hitachi magic wand there's
also a potato masher
yeah just don't eat the josh's if you
cook
yeah don't trust the potatoes at least
oh man anyway so i have a lot of things
that are multi-purpose and also
i vigorously rigorously
apply the seasonality rule to the
kitchen
if i have not used something in 90 days
it is
in fact i just got rid of some so that
that air fryer that we
i mentioned it had this like chicken
rotisserie thing
which sounds great aspirationally yeah
i'm not gonna make rotisserie chicken
at home and do you know how i know that
because i've never made rotisserie
chicken at home
i did once when i was 23. you leave that
up to the colonel
[Laughter]
no dude like how easy is it to get a
rotisserie chicken too like especially
your air one or whole foods i mean it's
pretty simple to go yeah
anywhere if you want a rotisserie
chicken you you can get one
and i get i by the way i got a
rotisserie chicken maker it was the only
thing it did as a wedding gift
when i was 22 23 oh wow and we used it
once
and then it sat on a counter for seven
years
because i had none of these boundaries
right available to me
and eventually i remember looking at
carrie hey we don't ever use this do we
she's like no but you know like we might
want to use it someday
cousin john got it for us we got to keep
it yeah and oh yeah we might want to use
it it's back to those narratives we were
telling ourselves
it's practically brand new well it's
practically brand new because we never
freaking use the thing that's the only
reason it's practically brand new
yeah and so yes your kitchen
probably is a key place in your home
in which you can hide color clutter well
why because there's a lot of drawers a
lot of cabinets
a lot of extra space even in my little
kitchen
we have a lot of things in cabins and
drawers now i keep things ordinal and
organized in there but i'm constantly
using that seasonality rule
yeah by the way if you want the
seasonality rule it's in love people use
things i'll hold it up you're watching
the video version here
or you can download the free version of
the
16 rules for living with less it's
called the minimalist rule book the
themminimalists.com
rulebook there's also an audiobook
version of that over there
as well one of the things that i do in
my kitchen that are
interesting that i think are worth
mentioning here so you mentioned the
cupboards you mentioned the fridge you
mentioned the freezer
right well these are all areas that we
sort of because there's a door
it's a place that we hide our things and
even though we see it every day we open
the fridge every day or ten times of
there 40 times a day however many times
we're going over there staring at the
fridge expecting a different result
by the way oh look all the same nonsense
that's in there
oh look ketchup right we open up the
fridge
and yet all of the condiments and
i got to tell you i know you will
resonate with this because you're the
sauce king
yes and and back they call me captain
sauce oh okay
well bex is your co-captain apparently
because the thing is and the weird thing
is like we have all these condiments and
they tend to expire so i'm the one who's
i'm just
constantly every week just looking at
expiration dates oh yeah and as soon as
something expires
that's a boundary it's gone yeah guess
what i'm not doing i'm not donating i'm
not trying to sell it
i know that it has to go right
and so creating these boundaries are so
important when i look around at
all of the kitchen utensils if it's not
if i haven't used it in 90 days it's
gone
if i know i'm not going to use it in the
next 90 days it
is gone yeah i mean any of these mounted
like my boundaries are
i mean a lot looser than yours but you
know with mariah and i
we look at the space we have and
how does that space feel it's like i
don't mind having you know my
kettle on top of the counter and i have
a coffee grinder on top of the counter
um but there are things that like i
don't want to look at every single day
so then i put them in the cupboards
right
and then i just kind of you know analyze
like okay what
uh what what is what is nagging at me
and if nothing's nagging at me then i
don't feel compelled to go into my
kitchen and start decluttering
but obviously this person this uh
katrina
it is it is nat or katarina sorry
it's nagging at her so that's where
these boundaries have to come into play
yeah what's bothering you about your
kitchen yeah that's the reason you want
to simplify not because
you don't simply want to tidy up you
want to
relieve the burden that you're
experiencing
and the only way we do that is by
letting go what do you have in your life
that you don't want
that you wish you didn't have you can
start in your kitchen with that katarina
yeah did you enjoy this video if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free